order order the eyes to the right 286
the nose to the left 344
[Applause]
the eyes to the right 286 the nose to
the left 344 so the noes have it
the noes have it unlock point of order
the Prime Minister Mr Speaker I think it
should be a matter of profound regret to
every member of this house the once
again we have been unable to support
leaving the European the implications of
the houses decision are grave the legal
default now is that United Kingdom is
due to leave the European Union on the
12th of April in just 14 days time that
is not enough time to agree legislate
for and ratify a deal and yet to the
house has been clear it will not permit
leaving without a deal and so we will
have to agree an alternative way forward
the European Union has been clear that
any further extension will need to have
a clear third purpose and will need to
be agreed unanimously by the heads of
the other 27 member states ahead of the
12th of April it is almost certain to
involve the United Kingdom being
required to hold European parliamentary
elections
on Monday on Monday this house will
continue the process to see if there is
a stable majority for a particular
alternative version of our future
relationship with the EU of course all
of the options will require the
withdrawal agreement
Mr Speaker I fear we are reaching the
limits of this process in this house
this house this house has rejected No
Deal
it has rejected no brexit on Wednesday
it rejected all the variations of the
deal on the table and today it has
rejected approving the withdrawal
agreement alone and continuing a process
on the future this government will
continue to press the case for the
orderly brexit that the result of the
referendum demands
[Applause]